okay hey
I'm alive
[Music]
hello NDC Oslo
have you had a great week
let's come on I know you're Norwegian
but you can make a bit of noise all
right
it's been fantastic it's been sold out
last year it was come about two-thirds
full so we are back to full strength I
have had a fantastic week met a bunch of
people I liked two of them which was
nice uh
um so yeah so before I start this I just
wanna get everyone uh there's a lot of
work that goes into this so to start off
with as the NDC crew Jacob chesty
Steiner Henriette all those guys who
plan these things and work out the
agenda and everything so let's have a
round of applause for the NDC crew
and then there are all these people
around the edge of the room who've been
working hard keeping us fed all week
just from the start of the conference to
the end all this delicious food so let's
have a round of applause for the
caterers
and then I have to do this because
otherwise I'll cut my mic off there's
the technical people who've been doing
the cameras and the screens and the
audio and all that sort of stuff so
round of applause for them
and of course all these people on the
Expo floor all the sponsors all the
people with stands without whom your
ticket would have cost three times as
much and your company would never have
paid for it so a round of applause for
the sponsors
and then there's a whole bunch of
volunteers who've been scanning Badges
and all that sort of stuff and probably
some other people I've forgotten the
security people all that sort of thing
so round of applause for everybody else
and then at this point some people would
say and give yourselves a round of
applause but I don't understand that you
know
you've come here you've had a great time
why does that get now give yourselves a
round of applause for turning up as well
so
I am here to finish off you're all
exhausted you've had lots of technical
content you've been taught how to do
microservices properly and then someone
else saying no that's not how you do
microservices properly so and and other
things and so the last slot they finally
just went you know what sod it we'll
just let Mark do his thing on the main
stage yay
um so I am just gonna basically talk
bollocks I might accidentally teach you
something for which I apologize in
advance but this is weird I've got
people behind me
it's like yeah okay fine
um so yes but we're going to talk about
some of the greatest mistakes in the
history of programming and I just want
to clarify at the start so first thing
I'm probably going to swear
because it's live streaming on NDC
conferences YouTube channel so that'll
probably get a strike against them so
that's fun but if you are sensitive to
bad language you should probably just
off now
um I'm going to talk about mistakes but
I'm not going to talk about any things
that any sort of software errors that
have killed people because that's not
funny
um but just just do bear in mind that
software has killed people uh in the
past I'm also not going to talk about
any um airplanes stuff because I'm aware
that quite a lot of people are going to
be going straight to the airport from
here and you don't need to hear about
that so yeah
um speaking of mistakes so I did this
talk at NDC Copenhagen earlier this year
and it went up on YouTube and so I would
just like to thank all these people on
YouTube for finding the mistakes in that
version of The Talk which I have fixed
in this version of the talk so thank you
very much YouTube people
just to make this Fair because you know
I am in no way blameless I want to talk
about one of the mistakes I have made uh
in my career as a programmer which is
now
33 years and counting
um and it's the midfiel unfucker
so I think I was
27 28 and I worked at a company and we
had a piece of software that did very
complicated queries and you could save
these queries out as a file with a DOT
Med extension I have no way I can't
remember what Med stood for
and we released a version of this
software uh that corrupted those files
but it corrupted them in a reversible
way I think somebody spelled a field
name wrong or something and so the
support chap came to me and said Mark
Mark the med files are
can you do something to fix them and I
you want me to write something to unfuck
the mid files and he said yes and so I
booted up Visual Basic six
that was not the mistake that was just a
mistake
um so I booted up visual Visual Basic
six and uh I I created this little
Standalone application and I I honestly
can't tell you why I did this at the
time but I called it
um Med file unfucker
and so it brought up a little dialog box
that had a file selection thing
um and the label on that said choose
file to unfuck
and you clicked it and you browsed and
you found you made file and then there
was a big button at the bottom of the
dialogue that said unfucknow
and you clicked that
and then it did the thing and then it
popped up a message box saying mid file
successfully unfucked
and so I gave this to the support guy
and said there you go just test that
make sure it works and he heard that as
Please Release this to the customer
immediately
uh in my defense that the file was
called medfile unfucker.exe
so you know he obviously didn't even
look at the file name so yeah that that
was an interesting one the customer was
not happy
um uh I I somehow managed to keep my job
uh basically because I was the only
person in the company who could do
things like write mid file on
um
but I did not get a good performance
review that year
okay let's move on to some more kind of
global mistakes with a higher
um price attached to them and obviously
one of those is Y2K
so uh I'm 50 years old next birthday I
was actually there and I had to do some
of the stuff to fix the Y2K bug and we
all worked incredibly hard on it and
then we got through the the Millennium
and nothing happened and people went oh
that was a lot of fuss about nothing
um and yeah thanks everyone but so the
Y2K bug the thing is to understand the
Y2K bug you you have to remember what
computer software was like in the 1950s
and 60s because that's when it started
so data was stored on Punch Cards and
like each column of that punch card is
one byte of data and so this was a very
expensive way to to store data and while
it was actually in the computer and it
was being worked on computers in those
days used magnetic core memory this was
amazing stuff so every one of those pins
has got two wires running through it and
they were actually made by hand mostly
by women with microscopes passing these
wires through these uh these pins and
the cost of magnetic core memory in the
early days was about one dollar per bit
so a byte cost you eight dollars and so
it was important to use as few bytes as
possible and so the standard date type
in Cobalt which was the language of the
time was a pick nine of six that's uh a
number
with six digits six bytes because that
saved sixteen dollars in memory space
and if you've got a whole sort of day's
run of stock trading or or sales for
Walmart or whatever going through your
system that's a lot of dollars that
you're saving also it was the 1950s so
the year 2000 no there's no way people
were still going to be using your COBOL
software in the year 2000 these have
been replaced by then won't it yes yes
of course it will if not then Mark and a
bunch of other idiots will come along
and fix it I learned COBOL just enough
to go through and change all those pick
nine sixes to pick nine eights and then
try and fix the underlying db2 things
but this is Bob Beamer and Bob Beamer in
1958 was going hey this is going to be a
problem and I know that we can't do
anything about it now I'm just raising
it it and can we put like an item in the
backlog for when we invent agile to
to fix the Y2K bug when we can do it in
a nice relaxed and and not crunchy kind
of way
and then in 1968 he went I noticed we're
still not talking about the Y2K thing
and in 1978 he said I noticed we're not
still not talking about the Y2K thing in
1988 people started going oh we should
probably start thinking about that Y2K
thing it was actually like
1995 before the newspapers got hold of
this idea of a Y2K bug and then all the
companies were like we actually
need to fix this now and so people who
still knew COBOL at that time who had
retired 20 years previously were getting
phone calls going how much would you
charge to come and do this and they went
oh I don't know 20 000 a day maybe yeah
that should do it and so estimates of
how much the Y2K bug ended up costing uh
kind of they vary but the middle of it
is about 500 billion dollars was spent
fixed using the Y2K bug and some of that
code that was being fixed had been
written in like 1992-93 so people were
still writing new code with the Y2K bug
in it
and so you'd think we'd learn from that
and we wouldn't do that again would we
so this year there was actually a y2k22
bug with Microsoft Exchange you probably
remember this showing up in the log
files of exchange because it was using
uh a 32-bit integer to represent dates
or something and it couldn't convert
220101 which is actually obviously the
date just formatted as yyy mm-dd or
something and then put into an integer
for some reason so as soon as it went to
22 at the start that doesn't fit in an
integer signed integer obviously
um and so that that went wrong as well
there's
y2k38 or the apocalypse which is the
Linux problem where they were using a
signed 32-bit integer to represent the
date and time they've now switched to
assigned 64-bit integer which should
take us up to
um well we're all going to be dead
like the entire human race the sun will
have expanded and absorbed the Earth and
we will still be on it because Elon Musk
will have died and he's the only person
who cares
um
there's a fantastic one though that I
found out about from a YouTube channel
called Stand Up maths while I was
researching this talk
um The Kennel Club of the United States
of America
had have a dog 38 bug
so when you register your dog with the
Kennel Club your pure breed
um Shih Tzu or whatever it might be uh
they have
a dog with your dog's show name
um and the breed and then if there's
already another one then your dog
becomes number two and number three and
number four and number five and so on
and so on until you get to dog 38 and
then you try to insert that into the
database and it crashes can anybody
guess why it crashes on the number 38.
how do you think they are storing that
number in the database
Roman numerals correct
every number up to
fits into uh six Roman numerals uh so
the field that stores the dog number in
the database is not an integer it is hr6
and so when you get to 38 which is xXx v
i i i
um as opposed to like XXX uh I X which
would have made sense then that's it it
dies it chokes you can't put your dog in
you can put dog 39 in though because
that goes back to just being x x x i x
um so yeah
all right moving on from Y2K but in a
kind of related way because these were
the people who caused and suffered from
the Y2K bug we have enterprise software
development
because
it's a mistake
um
I don't like doing the dictionary thing
but the dictionary Enterprise a business
plan or project especially one that is
difficult or that may fail or lose money
and you sort of thing yes it's and
actually it's more likely to fail or
lose money because of enterprise
software patterns and practices no
offense Microsoft
this
is an Enterprise
agile software development model this is
safe scaled agile for lean Enterprises
so yeah they sell posters of this that
you can buy and put up on the wall of
your developers office because they are
that proud of it and I had there were
YouTube comments going oh as I was with
him until he knocked safe and then I
lost interest there's nothing wrong with
safe it's perfectly good so yeah I'm not
drilling into that any further than I
have to
um this is auto scrum 1.1 this is
accenture's version of scrum so you know
I know scrum as Five Arrows going round
in a circle and that's it but no
Accenture this is a version of scrum I
don't even want to know and then uh you
might actually have seen this one
because it was quite popular at the time
this is
deloitte's agile landscape road map
version three where the scaled agile
framework for lean Enterprises and
accenture's auto scrum are just one node
hidden somewhere on this absolute
abomination
and I did experience uh enterprise
software I mean I've done enterprise
software developments and sometimes it's
been super painful and sometimes it's
actually not been too bad and sometimes
you're kind of like well yeah okay
finance software
um Mission critical systems like running
trains and planes and that sort of stuff
yeah you need those additional sort of I
shouldn't just be able to deploy to
production simply by pushing to a GitHub
Branch so you do need some stuff but uh
back in
the mid-noughties I was working for a
company we did a lot of Consulting and
we got a call from one of the uh UK's
kind of non-governmental autonomous
agencies
um quasi-autonomous non-governmental
organization quango that was a word in
the naughties and I'm not going to say
which one it is but they had an API
endpoint that was unsecured you could
hit it anonymously it didn't have any IP
throttling or anything so you could hit
it as often as you wanted and the data
that it returned was incredibly useful
if you were investing in certain Futures
on the stock market
and so obviously all the investment
funds and investment Banks and
everything were just hitting this thing
and then not doing a thread.sleep at all
and then just hitting it again
and it kept crashing about once every 20
minutes it would crash
and reboot because it was a.net service
running an IIs so the Apple would
recycle and so they hired me to review
the code
and not fix it
they hired me they paid me two weeks of
a very expensive day rate to document
what was wrong with the system and how
to fix it
and so I went and I got the code and I
loaded it up
uh and I had resharper installed and
resharper burst into tears and
uninstalled itself and refused to come
out until I made that code go away
and I thought you know the easiest way
to work out how to fix this is to fix it
and then tell them what I did
um and the primary thing that was
causing a problem slightly technical
thing uh for if you're not a net
developer we have this thing in dot net
called idisposable if if a class
implements are you disposable then when
you're finished with it you have to call
dispose on it and this is such a common
thing that we have a using statement so
you can put that variable into a using
block and then when that block finishes
it will be disposed and one of the key
things that you always have to do this
with is database connection objects
because they're really expensive and
there is a limited number of them and
they use a lot of memory and this
application was talking to an Oracle
database and there were about 20 places
where they were creating an oracle DB
connection and in none of them were they
disposing of that connection when they
were finished with it so this
application was leaking enormous amounts
of memory tying up all the Oracle
database space connections and then
crashing that was the point at which
these connections got disposed so I
added using statements to these 20
places and it fixed it and then I went
through and it's like okay that was 30
minutes what am I going to do for the
next two weeks
I'll dock it put using statements on
these things
we can't charge them 25 000 pounds for
that so I went through the rest of the
code and I found some stuff but the
other thing was this was.net 1.1 system
and it was 32-bit and this was when.net
4.0 I think was the current version and
we had 64-bit servers and they had it
running on a single server so there was
no kind of load balancing or anything
like that
so we sent this report back off to them
and I just assumed that they'd like read
the report and gone oh that's easy and
fixed it six months later we get another
reach out from them saying Oh right
we've set up a meeting with all the
stakeholders would you mind coming to
discuss your report I was kind of like
yeah okay we'll come up and discuss the
report so I turn up and at this point I
discover that the
these people all their I.T is actually
handled and managed by I won't say the
name of the company but it's three
letters and uh they're the ones after
Hal in the alphabet
so me and my boss turn up to this
meeting and uh there are eight
Consultants from the
this this place consultancy
um plus the CEO of the data center where
the application is currently hosted plus
the CEO of the data center where it's
going to be migrated to plus three of
the senior people from the actual
organization in question and probably a
couple of others and they they sit down
they go so this thing about using
statements is that going to cause any
changes in the applications behavior and
I said yes it won't crash every 20
minutes
I said yeah but could it have any
unintended side effects and I'm like no
unlike not using them which causes your
application to crash every 20 minutes
and they went okay so we'll we'll need
to sort of be careful about this because
this is a mission critical system
and I said it's a mission critical
system that crashes every 20 minutes
and I said you know you could also if
you really wanted to you could fix this
just by buying a new server and running
it on that instead and putting like a
gig a terabyte of memory in it and then
it would probably only crash every 24
hours and even in 2005 that server would
still cost less than this meeting
and my boss went March you want to go
outside and and get some fresh air which
meant go and have a cigarette because I
smoked at the time and I thought oh
Christ is he's going to be so pissed off
and so I went out and I stood by his car
and I'm smoking a cigarette and then
five minutes later he comes out and when
I told him to stuff it bunch of idiots
so it's unclear how much enterprise
software development has cost over the
years but probably trillions of pounds
actually probably just the governmental
stuff has cost trillions of pounds so
yeah
all right
the Pentium floating Point Unit this was
a fun one you might remember this so
this was the Intel Pentium the Pentium
was the first CPU from Intel where they
all had a floating Point Unit built in
so the 386 and the 486 they had a DX
version that had a floating Point Unit
and an SX version that didn't and you
could actually buy an add-on floating
Point Unit for the 386 and the 486 if
you decided you wanted it later but the
Pentium had it built in and they had
verified all of the uh micro codes for
the Pentium processor actually using
Haskell they write the micro code
verification in in Haskell
um and so they they were absolutely
convinced that this was all right and so
you know process is really hard to fix a
bug in a processor you don't want them
so
um four million 195 835 divided by three
million one hundred and forty five
thousand seven hundred and twenty seven
is actually 1.3382
according to the Pentium it was 1.3374
which you might think sounds like a
little thing and most sums worked but
there were a few like this that didn't
and if you actually needed that number
to be right when you ran it through your
Pentium using the the floating Point
Unit instructions this was kind of a
problem and so Intel had to go and say
all right if you are actually hitting
this bug if you can demonstrate that you
are hitting this bug we will replace
your Pentium with a new Pentium
um and then they had so many people just
coming up with ways to say oh no I am
definitely hitting this bug they just
went fine we will just replace all of
them at a cost of 475 million dollars
so yeah that one was fun
all right
null
I mean everyone knows the value of this
Tony Hall the guy who
um he invented null basically and so
these days when you've got kind of rust
people with their option types and uh
and various F sharp with its maybe and
all this kind of thing
um going oh you just shouldn't have
nulls nulls were a bad idea in the first
place but Tony horse uh Charles Anthony
Richard Tony Hall fellow of the Royal
Society
um created algol W which was the first
language that had records or structs
objects that contained multiple values
and so when you've got a record and then
another record has a reference to that
record there is a possibility that it
won't be said so it's like before that
if you had a string that didn't have
anything in it it was just a zero length
string if you had a number that didn't
have anything in it it was Zero but
suddenly got this idea of pointers to
objects on a heap and so if you have
something and there is no pointer to an
object on the Heap back in the 19 late
60s I think then you have to have
something that that can be when it's not
set and so it had the keyword null it's
first language to have a null keyword
um and so it it really it wasn't a
mistake at the time because the if you
look at things like rust's option type
and so forth they use more memory they
are more expensive and so null just
going well it's a pointer so if it's
zero because a pointer is just an
integer so if it's zero that's a null
pointer it made perfect sense but um he
in a talk that he gave at qcom a few
years ago referred to it as his billion
dollar mistake and uh so hands up you if
you've had something explode in
production because of a null reference
exception or the equivalent thereof
undefined has no member length and so on
and so forth so yeah that's a billion
dollars
at least I would say probably more
sometimes programming fuckups can cause
actual physical problems in the real
world
so the Hartford Center in the United
States
was built in the 1970s
and in the 1970s they had computer-aided
design software but it wasn't like
AutoCAD because we didn't have graphical
user interfaces so computer-aided design
software was more like Matlab without
the visualizations you would put your
numbers in and it would give you numbers
out and it would tell you about the
strains and stresses and it knew about
the tensile strengths of various kinds
of Steel and the load-bearing abilities
of L joists and and all this sort of
thing and so somebody used a a
computer-aided design system and
programmed it with all the things uh
necessary to build the Hartford centers
kind of Steel infrastructure and it was
good and so he sent it off to the
Architects and The Architects sent it to
the builders and the builders put it
together and it was fine and it hosted
lots of lots of events and it looked
great and everybody loved it and then it
snowed and this happened
because
the person who was doing the software
had put in what should have been a
horizontal Shear Force as a vertical
Shear force and so when the snow that
was on the roof of the Hartford Center
slid sideways and created horizontal
Force the whole thing just collapsed
so yeah
um I've I've never made an error in in
an application and then been able to go
out and stand in the street and take a
photograph of what went wrong because of
it
um it's on my bucket list
um
one day and then I'll come back and I'll
tell you all about it
um so yeah that costs 90 million dollars
to to fix that to put the roof back on
fortunately so there'd been a concert
there that evening but everybody had
left the building there was no one in
the building when that happened
Knight capital
night capital is a hedge fund and that
basically means that they deserved this
that I'm about to tell you about so
because let's just talk about the stock
market quickly the stock market the
Dutch India Trading Company uh needed to
build lots of ships so that they could
go and plunder India and steal all its
stuff and bring it back and sell it to
European people and so they needed money
to build the boats and so they said all
right we will sell shares in the company
and then use that money to build the
boats and then when we come back and
sell the stuff we will give you your
share of the profits that we make from
doing this and then uh the people who
had bought the shares started selling
them to each other and that was how the
first stock markets
um popped up in in Amsterdam and uh or
Rotterdam I think
um and Antwerp and places like that
somehow
400 years later that has turned into
extremely highly tuned C plus plus
programs operating entirely autonomously
on remote servers doing trades in
fractions of a millisecond to try and
cream off
0.01 of the difference in the value of a
share from one second to the next
um and this
this was happening in 2010 2011 and
these were called Dark pools these
places where these automated trading
Bots effectively would just compete with
each other and so the only thing that
people were trying to do was make their
bot better than all the other Bots and
sometimes that was optimizing it and
sometimes that was improving the
algorithms and the predictions and
everything this is a job title Quant is
there anyone here whose job title is
Quant by the way
No One's Gonna admit it now are
they
so there's all this dark pool trading
going on and the New York Stock Exchange
is seeing a downturn in trades going
through their systems because all the
trading is happening in these dark pools
and so they worked with the um
the americ SEC
um security is an Exchange Commission to
make these dark Falls illegal but then
they created the official dark pool for
all these things to run in and so night
Capital
um had a thing that had been running in
these dark pools called the smart access
routing system power Peg
um and they had six weeks to rewrite
this software to make it compatible with
the New York stock exchanges new system
and so obviously they copied and pasted
a lot of code and copying and pasting
code may be a theme through some of
these remaining uh mistakes and so they
reused a flag that on their previous
system had marked the uh the trade as a
test trade do not actually run this
trade we're just testing it to see if
it's some something that we want to put
live and then they shipped it and they
had hired eight machines in this dark
pool running inside the New York Stock
Exchange to run this code and they
launched it and by ten past nine on the
morning that they launched it it had
bought 90 million dollars worth of
stocks and it shouldn't have done that
and then they watched it and by half
past nine it had bought 200 million
dollars worth of stocks and they uh no
sorry two billion dollars worth of
stocks 2 billion
and they went okay we haven't got two
billion dollars we can't actually settle
this at the end of the day and then they
noticed that of the eight machines they
deployed to
seven of the deployments had worked and
one of them hadn't worked and so they
thought oh well it's obviously that one
that's that's causing the problem and so
then they deployed to that one as well
and the problem got worse so that by
quarter to ten they spent four billion
dollars turns out that the one that
hadn't updated was the only one that
didn't have the problem
and so they basically had to shut the
thing down and you you have to settle up
your trades by the end of the day and so
they had to go begging to Goldman Sachs
and say please give us the money uh to
to pay off these trades by the end of
the day
um and uh Goldman Sachs said yeah all
right we'll give you the money and then
we're gonna buy your company for 450
million dollars
which is not what they thought it was
worth
like I say hedge fund totally deserved
it
okay
um
the title of this next section makes
sense if you were a fan of the Muppets
in the 1970s
yeah just me
a couple of people but yes no there was
a Pigs in Space thing
um I I thought that was great and then I
did it in London at the start of this
year and everyone was just like what
okay
so let's do this instead in space no one
can set a break point
so
all spacecraft are driven by software
since the beginning of spacecraft
because uh they're too complicated for
people to drive even if there are people
on them but the vast majority of
spacecraft don't have people on them
because they have a tendency to explode
and people kind of go I don't want to
sit on the top of that enormous stack of
very explosive stuff that you've put
there it might explode and so we have to
automate our spacecraft so one of the
earliest examples of this was the
Mariner one spacecraft which was
supposed to go off and look at planets
and send photographs back
and this has been referred to as the
most expensive hyphen in history
so this is what Mariner one would have
looked like had it made it into space
and it had gone off and it would have
done a planetary flyby of Venus and
taken the photographs and sent those
back to NASA
um
Mariner 2 did actually work but Mariner
won not so much and this wasn't actually
a programming mistake it was a
specification mistake so if there are
any business analysts in the room yeah
you don't get off either it's you're
just as bad as us this was the bug
so
uh the handwritten guidance equations
that somebody had given to the
programmer to encode using probably
Fortran I'm guessing
um had an r in it and it should have had
a line over the top of it and the line
over the R so R is for radius and the
line over the R means smoothed over time
so this value is going to go
like that and what your algorithm needs
to do is smooth that out and find the
midpoint between the highs and the lows
and that's what we want to plot but it
didn't do that because they didn't put
the hyphen in there and so the
programmer who doesn't know anything
about guidance systems they just know
how to convert mathematical equations
into Fortran puts the thing in there and
as soon as it started ascending the
booster lost its uh its connection
um lost guidance lock with the ground
um and the uh rocket it was on was
designed to continue on a pre-programmed
course when the lock was re-established
the faulty guidance logic caused the
program to erroneously report that the
velocity was fluctuating in an erratic
and unpredictable manner which of course
it was because it was supposed to be
smooth and it was jumping up and down
all over the place and so the range
safety officer actually pushed a button
and blew up the rocket and Mariner won
along with it at a cost to NASA of 10
million dollars which doesn't sound like
a lot but in today's money that's like a
hundred million or something
that actually that incident was what led
to the creation of software engineering
as a discipline they were kind of like
how can we stop this from happening
again it was the thing where they said
okay we're going to have clearly defined
roles and training and degrees and
things that people can go and do in the
same way as they would for building a
bridge
but it didn't stop them from messing up
so the Mars climate Orbiter this was
supposed to go to Mars and it was
supposed to go into orbit around Mars
and monitor the atmosphere and send that
data back to NASA so they could work out
how much oxygen and nitrogen and carbon
dioxide and all that sort of thing was
supposed to be in there so this is what
the Mars climate Orbiter would have
looked like above Mars if it had
actually made it
um on September the 23rd 1999
communication with the spacecraft was
permanently lost as it went into orbital
insertion
the spacecraft encountered Mars on a
trajectory that brought it too close to
the planet and it was either destroyed
in the atmosphere or escaped the
planet's vicinity and entered an orbit
around the sun
which would probably have killed it they
don't know they don't know why because
they lost Telemetry to it and you can't
have a telescope pointed a tiny little
chunk of metal that's supposed to be in
orbit around Mars they have no idea
which one of those things happened it's
brilliant
so what caused that problem
units
so
the entire world uses the metric system
metric system is very sensible
everything is based on kind of One Core
element you've got a millimeter
um and a kilogram and a liter and one
liter of water weighs one kilogram and
then you just divide things up by tens
and hundreds and thousands and all this
sort of stuff and it's a nice Easy
System we've got ten fingers if it comes
down to it you can do it on your fingers
except America where they use feet and
inches and miles and gallons and quarts
and all that sort of stuff because
because they're different
they're just they're not like us that's
that's all it is now for this system and
actually for all NASA systems at the
time NASA had basically turned around to
the United States and said just we're
using the metric system you all can
carry on doing whatever you want to do
we are using the metric system from now
on and so all the contractors there are
a lot of contractors involved in
building NASA projects and all the
contracts were so we're using the metric
system and they did across all the code
except one piece of code from Lockheed
Martin
which they have copied and pasted from
an earlier project which used feet and
inches and so unfortunately this was the
piece of software that controlled the
orbital insertion of the Mars climate
Orbiter which meant that
um well just for clarification
um if this is a person who is uh
uh two feet tall now if this is a person
who is six feet tall this is a person
who is six meters tall
um it's it's quite a big difference and
so when the uh the Orbiter came to Mars
it's planned trajectory was uh uh 226
kilometers above the surface of the
planet it actually came in 57 kilometers
above the surface of the planet
um NASA have said that uh we were at
fault for failing to make the
appropriate checks and uh tests that
would have caught this discrepancy
because you can't slag off Lockheed
Martin because otherwise they'll stop
making bombs for you
that one 327 million dollars
so yes haha silly Americans blowing up
Rockets we would never do that here in
Europe we're much more intelligent than
the Americans oh no
Ariane 5 the French
space company but basically the European
Space Agency we all cooperate on the
Ariane project so the Ariane 4 had been
in service and delivering things to
orbit perfectly well for years and years
and years and Ariane 5 was the the
replacement for the Ariane IV and
um
this is the launch of the Ariane 4 on
the 4th of June
1996 and everything went absolutely fine
the Rockets lit at exactly the right
time and the spacecraft soared
majestically into the sky and
took off and started heading for orbit
and literally like the crown heads of
Europe and the presidents and the prime
ministers and everybody had been invited
to the Spaceport to to view this
historic launch and it just it shot up
into the sky and it was the most
powerful rocket that had ever been built
outside of the United States of America
and everyone was really really excited
about it and it was a striking a blow
and oh
guess
they copied and pasted code from Ariane
IV
so they copied and pasted some code
which resulted in them trying to store a
4-bit floating Point number in an
address that held a 16-bit signed
integer which represented horizontal
bias
um this caused a processor trap operand
error because the floating point value
was too large to be represented by a
16-bit integer
um
and this essentially told the Ariane
rocket that something was well out of
its operable range and caused its
on-board systems to self-destruct the
rocket so that they could at least
control where the pieces landed I think
so yes
um so they grounded that and then they
fixed it and they took out the copied
and basted code and then everything
worked at a cost of half a billion
dollars
okay let's bring it back to to something
that we can sort of identify I've been
to people anyone here work on Rocket
guidance systems
and copy and paste code
again no one's got yeah I do
let's bring it back to something that we
can all identify with the big rewrite
so yes new and improved new and proved
oh we've written this application and we
use angularjs 1.0 and that's that's old
now we have to rewrite it to use react
because Facebook
um and so I have been guilty of this I
am I I have learned from my mistakes and
I don't do this anymore I will finish a
system in the language it started in uh
but back in the day I was very
distracted by shiny things
and actually the same company where I
wrote the mid file on
um once they'd forgiven me for that we
had our main application was written in
something called Gupta SQL windows
be like one person maybe in the room who
actually has heard of Gupta SQL Windows
anyone
yes there he is at the back is like
playing where's Wally
um
and yeah this this was not a development
platform with a future and they were
like we need to rewrite it and Dot net
had just appeared
um dot net 2.0 when I was coming up we
should rewrite it in.net because you
know uh we've got some VB stuff and
there's Visual basic.net and so we could
probably copy some code across but I'm
going to write it in the C sharp I'm
going to write it in Windows forms and
so I got uh permission to go ahead with
this and I started porting this system
from group to SQL Windows to c-sharp and
windows forms and there was me doing
that and there were four people
maintaining and adding features to the
existing software package and the idea
was that because I was a 10x programmer
um there was a face that went with that
um people behind me just in case they
think I actually think I'm a 10x
programmer I'm just a 10x idiot
um
so yeah you'll be able to catch up with
them quite easily and then eventually it
became obvious that that wasn't going to
happen and so they gave me another
person to help me and we were actually
catching up and we were getting there
and then Windows Vista happened and Dot
net 3 and 3.5 happened and WPF happened
and I thought well wpf's binding I had
been struggling with the windows forms
data binding system and wpf's data
binding system Windows forms data
binding you couldn't say
object.object.object so you can only
have one level of data binding WPF you
could do dot dot dot dot dot dot dot
right down into the
um
into the thing in violation of the
Damocles principle or whatever that is
and so so we should we should basically
keep the the library code we've written
and redo the entire UI in WPF WPF
version one by the way
um which was not without its issues and
so I decided I was going to do that uh
we worked on it for a few weeks then the
programmer that they had given me to
help me with this actually quit
um and so I was left trying to do it on
my own and by the end of that project I
was working a hundred hours a week
um I had a lap I made the company buy me
a laptop so I could work on the train on
the way in work through the day work on
the train on the way home and then carry
on working in the evening 100 110 hours
a week and then my brain snapped and I
had a complete breakdown and I went off
in and I was in uh hospital
um for six weeks and uh they they
scrapped the project and replaced it
with a different project that was all in
vb.net and said you can work on that and
I said can I and I quit
so yes I figure with what they were
paying me and the other developer and
various other things that was actually
probably about a hundred thousand pounds
down the drain and of course my sanity
um so yeah
recursion
um Fibonacci sequences and all this sort
of stuff so people oh you should use
recursion and you should use languages
that have tail call optimization to
handle your recursion because if you do
it in a language that doesn't have that
you will get a stack Overflow exception
you call a method that calls itself and
then it calls itself again and then it
calls itself again every time it does
one of those calls it puts the
parameters on the stack and eventually
the stack fills up and your program can
literally do nothing at that point
except crash
and so this is why generally we have
four loops and while loops and four
reach loops and do while loops and that
sort of thing because tail call
optimization is hard but um so this is
uh some code
um that
uh is compiled with the.net framework
the 32-bit version the 64-bit version of
the.net framework the jit does have tail
call optimization but if you compile it
with the 32-bit version the x86 version
it will just Chuck out this code which
will eventually get a stack Overflow if
you start it with a from that's big
enough compile it with x64 it does tail
call optimization
and you can see down at
l0014 it's doing a jump to l007
so it turns out that a tail call
optimization is just to go to
and I've proved this with the help of
sharp lab
by writing the same code with a loop
label and a go to Loop label and it
literally generates pretty much exactly
the same machine code so yes when people
go oh I use a tail call optimize
language and I use recursion to
represent my logic you just go uh yeah I
use go to so we're pretty much the same
when it all comes down to it
we'd like to shout out to Andrei Shakin
for creating sharp lab sharplab.io if
you want to see what your c-sharp code
is doing then go and type it into sharp
lab it will show you the IL code it will
show you the lowered c-sharp code where
they've done all the sort of async State
machines and all that kind of thing it
will show you the um and the actual
machine code that is produced by the jit
and it has every version of C sharp and
Dot net available so you can see you can
if they say oh we've improved this from
C sharp 10 to C sharp 11 you can go and
check for yourself and see what they've
done to improve it so yeah that's a
fantastic tool for for c-sharp
developers and follow Ash mind on
Twitter as well
okay I may lose some people on this next
one this is in my opinion this is one of
the big ones it's one of the biggest
mistakes in the history of programming
[Applause]
did anyone uh Dylan has this fantastic
thing where he does this sort of array
um binary order with not array gives you
the number three and then if you do
something in the cast it to a string and
you can basically get the entire
alphabet out of various uh string
conversions and error messages and there
is an esoteric coding language which is
just square brackets pipes and bang
symbols
21 letters
there are
there are five letters you can't get out
of JavaScript
um so yeah somebody should fix that
but yes so JavaScript famously
it was a tech demo for Netscape
Navigator 2.0
and somebody stuck their head around
Brendan Ike's door because Brendan was
kind of like the programming language he
was interested in programming languages
and he'd written his own lisp and all
this sort of stuff and they went brynden
could you knock up a scripting language
that we can stick in the browser so
people can make web pages interactive
and he went uh yeah all right and they
went can you have it ready by next
Friday and he went what
and so he went and he got the lisp that
he'd written and he made it work with
the document object model that they
already had in Netscape Navigator
exposed that as an object that was
visible to it and went back to them and
went how's this and they went ah see no
because that that's weird with all those
brackets and things and there's this hot
new thing that people are using for
interactive web pages called Java could
you make it look more like Java
and so Brendan turned it into something
that looked more like Java but then he
made various decisions alongside that
like well a lot of programmers who
aren't used to c-style languages won't
want to worry about semicolons so I'll
automatically insert semicolons for them
and various other mistakes which results
in
um array equals equals not array does
actually return true and as we saw
earlier if you saw Todd's JavaScript
quiz during lunch array equals equals
array is false we have this fantastic
expression
um
so what's happening here is we're doing
string concatenation which uses plus
except we've missed something in the
middle there so we've got two pluses in
a row and so what it JavaScript actually
tries to do there is uh coerce
um a to be a number so that it can make
it positive because if you say like
you've got a value that's minus three
and you say plus a then it will go now
is now plus three
um rather than doing math.abs or
something like that and so this tries to
make a positive can't make a positive
return it's not a number and so this
expression evaluates to banana
and then you've got
um the the document.all which was kind
of it was in there in the early versions
of things that JavaScript were working
with but in Netscape Navigator an
Internet Explorer it did different
things and so there was kind of a debate
so his document.all an instance of an
object well yes yes it is it's an object
um so type of document.all therefore
should be object shouldn't it no it
should be undefined okay so does
document.all equal and if I no no it
doesn't uh does document.all equal equal
does it actually equal null does it sort
of strictly with no type coercion equal
null no it doesn't does it kind of equal
null if we use only the W yes yes it
does yes it absolutely does
and
the problem is that that shipped and
people wrote code on it and so every
mistake every problem that JavaScript
shipped with has to be kept because
people have built features on the bugs
code is out there in static HTML Pages
hosted on geocities or wherever else and
if you change JavaScript then the
internet will stop working and honestly
I think that would be kind of a good
idea some days but but you know they
can't do it you can't fix JavaScript you
can put in things so you can put like
use strict in a string with a semicolon
which is valid JavaScript but will
actually be interpreted by modern
JavaScript interpreters to say hey turn
off some of those old bugs because they
were a really bad idea there is no put
in a string do not use automatic
semicolon insertion or ASI off or
anything like that which means return
new Line and an object will continue to
return undefined and this you know the
time that developers spend struggling
with JavaScript and going why won't you
work
but at the same time
the laughs we get out of it a the
stories we can share in the pub the
quizzes that Todd can put on the
software that Todd can sell
it's extremely good software and if
you're running JavaScript you really
should take a look at it track.js
fantastic tool
um
cash right US dollars as well not pounds
those are worth all now
honorable mentions heart bleed obviously
the open SSL Library
um so the openssl
free open source SSL Library maintained
by a few people who've never made a
penny from it Microsoft are using it
googly using it Amazon are using it
Facebook are using it Apple leaves
everybody's using it nobody's giving
them any money nobody's looking over
their code there's a bug in it and
suddenly SSL is complete and
everybody can steal your credit card
numbers log 4J quite a recent one so in
Java you can put in a URI that points to
a bean or something I don't know Java
and log4j will go and get that
bean and execute it so if you go right I
bet the thing that I put into this text
field here is going to be logs out into
log4j you can put your malevolent being
on a server somewhere and then put your
name in as Jay beam colon slash whatever
and log4j will execute your being in the
context of whatever it is and Javas
ecdsa algorithm this was actually in the
Java runtime until they patched it so
the ecdsa algorithm you give it three
numbers plus a whole bunch of weird text
and it says okay so if this number
multiplied by this number comes out uh
the modulus is zero then this is a valid
ecdsa key so if you pass in 0 0 and 0 I
may be getting this wrong it's something
like this but if you passed in three
zeros as that key it would just go yeah
no that's fine I've I've checked that
and the modulus of 0 and 0 is definitely
zero so yes
other things as well I will add to this
as people sort of tell me about stuff
but I want to finish on the Soviet early
warning system
um so
uh this is one of the things computers
do they keep us safe they let us know if
our enemies are firing missiles at us
because they've decided that Humanity
has had long enough and it's time for it
all to end and this is Lieutenant
Colonel stanislav Petrov
um and on the 26th of September 1983 he
was on duty monitoring the computers
that checked to see if the United States
had launched missiles against the Soviet
Union and suddenly it went Bing and said
yes they have they've launched five
missiles and stanislav had to go to
somebody and say the Americans have
launched missiles we need to retaliate
but he didn't
he went
seems unlikely that they just launched
five
who we know they've got hundreds if they
were gonna do it they launch all of them
wouldn't they they're not just going to
launch Five they're not just gonna take
out like these five cities and then sit
there and go hey what'd you think of
that
and so he decided that this was probably
a software and it was it was a software
error Soviet computers they weren't
great in 1983. you know we had the IBM
PC and they had some rocks that they
banged I don't know what they had
um
um but whatever
Russians leaving the room now
this guy he was good for the first
hour
so yeah
um he decided that he was going to
ignore this and it was actually the
sunlight glinting off clouds that had
triggered the satellite
um that thought that those were missiles
that had been launched and so he made
that call and basically saved all known
life in the universe from complete and
total Extinction so thank you stanisloff
God bless you
[Applause]
that's it for my mistakes go back to
your homes and make some more thank you
very much NDC
enjoy the rest of your year and I will
see you back here next time